here
root yourselves beside me i am that tree
planted by the river
which will not be moved with her reading
of
on the pulse of mourning when bill
clinton was first sworn in as president
in 1993
maya angelou became just the second poet
in history
to recite a poem at an inauguration
now she's making history again as one of
20 distinguished women
who are about to be honored by the u.s
mint appearing on a series of quarters
starting next year
being honored trailblazing astronaut
sally ride
who became the first american woman in
space on the shuttle challenger
in 1983. the women will be featured on
the reverse or
tail side of the coin starting next
january michelle thompson
is the project manager it's a huge deal
the american women quarters program
gives the
opportunity to have women out there on
circulating coins their legacies their
achievements they're all going to be
captured on pocket change for
generations
the us mint will oversee the design work
treasury secretary janet yellen will
approve the nominees and
final design and while the front or head
side will continue to feature a likeness
of george washington
he'll be getting a makeover to
distinguish the new coins
with several options being considered
the other 18 honorees who have yet to be
announced will come from a
wide variety of fields we're looking for
a very broad diverse group of women
because that's what we have in america
and they're the type of women who have
shaped where we are as a nation
about time hello i'm waiting on harriet
tubman
yes and on the is it the 2010 right
i think the 20 would be more appropriate
i can't remember do you remember i
thought it was a 20.
i did two yeah sorry memory the brownies
that's the brownies